est-ce que vous allez retirer vos
propres propos comme la demande et
gérald darmanin
non mais il n'en est absolument pas
question hier soir il ya eu un tweet qui
est raccourci mes propos mais quand on
écoute la séquence les choses sont
absolument claires et je veux dire aux
français qu'il y en a marre que monsieur
darmanin dès lors qu' il se sent mise en
question puisque là il était gêné aux
entournures sur la réponse une question
attaque l'opposition ce que je veux dire
c'est que hier monsieur darmana nous
attaquer pour islamophobie est
aujourd'hui m'attaquerai mois pour un
peu trop de complaisance vis-à-vis de
l'islamisme c'est lui monsieur darmanin
qu'il ya quelques années avait proposé
un concordat avec l'islam c'est à dire
c'est à dire un coup de canif un sérieux
coup de canif à la loi de séparation de
1905 c'est lui c'est par son inaction
qui tente de cacher finalement qu' il en
vient à attaquer ses adversaires
politiques c'est indigne
il a même proféré un mensonge je viens
d'avoir damien abad qui est le président
du groupe à l'assemblée nationale
monsieur meyer matin a dit devant les
sénateurs que monsieur abad m'avait
tacler c'est absolument faux c'est un
mensonge
il faut que les français sachent qui est
monsieur darmanin je tiens le dire et
c'est moi qui ai proposé l'interdiction
du voile pendant les sorties scolaires
des listes communautariste c'est nous
avec philippe bas qui ont proposé la
modification de la constitution pour que
la laïcité soit reconnue dès l'article 2
de notre norme suprême
donc ça suffit assez de mensonges ce que
les français demandent ça n'est pas de
mettre en cause d'opposition ce que les
français demandent ce sont des actes et
nous jugerons le gouvernement et
monsieur darmanin aux actes et non pas à
ces déclarations qui sont mensongères
parfois
[Musique]